oula
un mélange de country de funk et de
blues l'artiste américain popa chubby
sera à conflans sainte honorine le 8
novembre pour l'ouverture de blues sur
seine
ce festival itinérant en est à sa 21e
édition
au départ il se tenait uniquement à
mantes la jolie et s'est peu à peu
développé sur tout le territoire de la
vallée de la seine on est sur un public
voilà qui est propre au blues des
amoureux du blues souvent de longue date
et étonnamment aussi un public assez
jeune qui qui revient vers ce style de
plus en plus au fil des années objectif
de cette manifestation promouvoir le
blues en proposant public des têtes
d'affiché comme paul personne le 23
novembre à mantes la ville
dans l'année comme un os permet une
personne sur qui compter
[Musique]
ou encore andré manoukian et china moses
le 22 novembre à aubergenville
également l'occasion pour le public de
découvrir ou redécouvrir des artistes
plus jeunes il y en a certains qui
reviennent par exemple ça râle un cas
c'est une artiste qui revient pourquoi
parce que nous on à me dire c'est le la
programmation du public parce qu'elle
était venue l'année dernière elle avait
fait un tabac et on a eu beaucoup
d'appels de gens qui voulaient qu'on la
fasse revenir chez nous donc ouais on
aime dire que c'est là la date de la
date d du public il a programmé on l'a
remise la voix jazzy de camélia jordana
sera également séduire un public plus
jeune le 12 novembre à andrésy au total
blues sur seine propose une vingtaine de
concerts des rendez-vous of non des bars
partenaires et des actions dans les
ehpad et les établissements scolaires
[Musique]